[Musica]
Laura finalmente ci siamo
dalla Geopolitica alla Geo poesia sono
due parole che alludono al viaggio e
quindi ti faccio una domanda difficile
ma spero bellissimo se in questo momento
abbiamo 12 minuti tu volessi portare
tutto il pubblico che c'è oggi al
Ponchielli In viaggio con te come lo
faresti
io lo farei senza valigie senza pesi
senza borse e metterei tutti quanti su
un tapis roulant che è la posizione in
cui mi sento io Quando comincio a
disegnare per Limes osservo è la prima
cosa che faccio in silenzio leggo
moltissimi testi degli autori che
lavorano nella mia rivista e dico mia
perché io lavoro dal 1993 sono stata la
prima praticamente a iniziare il lavoro
di redazione e leggo le parole il bello
della nostra di questa rivista è che noi
ospitiamo opinioni di diversi punti di
vista e per analizzare i temi più
scottanti di politica internazionale
Quindi nel caso per esempio della guerra
che stiamo attraversando in Europa e sia
punti di vista ucraini Che russi
tedeschi europei questo è molto
importante per le parole che usiamo e il
nostro tapis roulant è meraviglioso
Perché in silenzio si osserva quello che
accade e per poter filtrare per poter
lasciare dentro di noi quello che serve
veramente
essenziale per capire ok Siamo tutti sul
tapis roulant con te quindi possiamo
cominciare il viaggio e ci hai parlato
appunto di difficoltà di questo momento
lo abbiamo sentito la Geopolitica si
occupa di relazioni fra la geografia
fisica la geografia dell'umanità la
geografia politica
quindi la complessità del mondo è
rappresentata nelle mappe Ma come si fa
a rappresentare la complessità del mondo
delle mappe in un momento in cui il
mondo sta attraversando una crisi
davvero che si preannuncia epocale e
stiamo anche iniziando a sentir parlare
di geografia dell'incertezza quando per
noi la geografia è qualcosa di definito
sull'atlante sul mappamondo Ecco diciamo
che le mappe che sono in un atlante per
me sono quanto di più falso passatemi il
termine Eh che possa esistere perché
quei confini che si vedono così nitidi o
questi colorini pastello con i quali
coloriamo le mappe politiche
sinceramente non corrispondono intorno
alla realtà alla realtà umana perché noi
stiamo parlando di una geografia di
tensione e di potere che disegnamo sul
mondo ho scelto questo di portare questa
mappa perché per noi della redazione di
Limes è fondamentale l'abbiamo disegnata
diversi anni fa si chiama caoslandia e
forse rappresentava secondo me per
questo tema un esempio di complessità
importante le mie mappe partono da un
nucleo centrale c'è un tema portante che
io chiamo il nocciolo come un'ancora la
quale legarsi e non filo lungo partire e
andare a vedere piano piano tutti i
concetti che costruiscono una mappa in
questo caso il nocciolo della mappa e
l'area di caoslandia sembra difficile ma
piano piano noi ci dobbiamo abituare a
leggerla complessità e io ehm osservo
bene il mio lavoro Una volta finito
perché cerco di vedere se una persona
che non ha mai trattato questi temi si
può orientare
nel caso di questa mappa il secondo
elemento oltre all'area che rappresenta
caoslandia sono le guerre come potete
vedere tutti i pallini verdi
rappresentano le guerre attive al
momento perché questa è una mappa
aggiornata che noi aggiorniamo
continuamente e ci serve anche per
ragionare in redazione quindi è proprio
un punto fermo diciamo E poi ci sono
alcuni gli Stati Uniti evidenziati
Naturalmente la Germania la Cina la
Russia tutti i grandi le grandi potenze
noi ci dobbiamo abituare a ragionare che
ci sono dei paesi come per esempio la
Russia che ricordo è il paese più grande
del mondo a 11 fusi orari e stiamo
parlando di un paese che copre
dall'Europa al Pacifico che non si
considerano degli Stati è un concetto
completamente diverso loro si
considerano un impero come gli Stati
Uniti e quindi hanno un approccio
diverso al mondo questo sarebbe un
passaggio importante per collegarmi
anche al discorso che ha fatto il mio
collega prima
attraverso un ragionamento più logico e
più aderente alla realtà Certo proprio
così infatti
è andata troppo avanti la
non fa niente salta comunque saltiamo
anche noi passiamo proprio a quello che
vi dicevi le mappe non sono dei disegni
statici Mi vien da dirti da come le
Descrivi Sembrano dei disegni in
movimento che continuano a cambiare
quindi attraverso linee colori tu in
realtà dai movimento è eri disegni il
mondo attraverso la mappa proprio per
questo cioè accennato i colori ma qual è
il ruolo dei colori nelle mappe per
arrivare poi a comunicare con le persone
I colori sono fondamentali perché un po'
come la musica toccano subito le corde
dell'anima vedere un colore violento
come potrebbe essere il rosso o il nero
diciamo si collega subito a dei
sentimenti nefasti sia quello Rossi per
esempio gli Stati Uniti sempre neri
nelle mie mappe naturalmente senza
neanche stare a leggere l'occhio delle
persone lo collocano lo colloca in una
situazione nefasta e pessima immaginate
Se lo facessi con la Cina o con la
Russia quindi i colori Io non ho mai una
stessa colorazione uno stesso paese ma
cambiano a seconda degli scenari ma la
cosa più importante di tutte è che io
non devo mai e non voglio è stato è
stata la cosa più complessa diciamo da
conquistare durante il corso della mia
vita è stata la mia posizione nei
confronti delle mappe quindi io dico
sempre sono un tre d'union sono una
persona che deve spiegare e far vedere
quello che l'autore scrive non entro mai
nel gioco né Semmai ruoto la mappa per
cercare di mettermi dentro i panni di
uno scenario dell'altro e i colori in
questo mi aiutano perché non danno una
connotazione violenta a nessuno riesco
penso ad avere a dare un approccio
equilibrato è chiaro che certe
situazioni
il mio obiettivo sarebbe quello di
daregli tutti gli strumenti necessari a
un lettore affinché diventi una parte
attiva
a conoscere piano piano i territori In
modo tale che possa poi ragionare verso
conto perché è facile ottenere una
manipolazione attraverso un'immagine
purtroppo Quindi io ci tengo moltissimo
alla mia etica ed è quello che io cerco
di fare guardate questa mappa per
esempio è la quella stessa di prima però
ho messo il nero sulla Russia ho messo
il rosso all'Unione Europea perché poi
in realtà il grande scontro adesso
avverrà qui e in quest'area qui e quindi
è già sta succedendo e quindi Mmm Questa
però questa colorazione pone subito un
un blocco dal punto di vista secondo me
di lettura e psicologico Invece noi non
dobbiamo avere paura di quello che
accade ma lo dobbiamo conoscere perché
la consapevolezza è una parte
fondamentale del poter studiare e poter
capire essere immersi nel mondo in cui
viviamo
e A questo proposito di paura
Non so perché Scusate saltano Ecco
questa mappa che è una mappa storica ehm
si chiama matrioska geografica che poi è
il titolo che hai dato al tuo intervento
e volevo sapere da dove nasce l'origine
di Matrioska geografica che è un po'
l'essenza del tuo lavoro ma visto che tu
hai disegnato più di 5000 mappe possiamo
dire che hai ridisegnato il mondo più e
più volte torniamo al concetto iniziale
di dove la geografia non è qualcosa di
statico ma in continuo movimento che si
ridisegna Sì infatti è una mappa
Geopolitica è assolutamente ehm compresa
in un spazio in un tempo ma questo
spazio e tempo e variabile per esempio
una mappa sulla guerra in nel giro di
due ore può cambiare esempio lo scorso
volume io ho pubblicato l'ultima mappa
sulla guerra dopo due ore c'è stata
l'offensiva ucraina per cui la mia mappa
è andata in stampa già vecchia e in
questo caso il web Cioè ci aiuta perché
io posso aggiornare e mettere sul web le
mappe nuove ma invece in questo caso era
il 199 67 era la mia prima mappa e mi
ricordo il direttore Caracciolo mi dice
Adesso mi devi disegnare la casa Manzo
la casa Io non ho mai sentito a nominare
questa cosa ero spazzata e non c'era
internet che potevi digitare su Google e
su nessuna Atlante c'era scritto casa
Manzo quindi ho dovuto fare una ricerca
in quei casi le ricerche hanno tutta
un'altra cosa tu Devo proprio prendere
gli atlanti interrogare le persone
finalmente trovo la Casa Mazza che è a
sud del Gambia e cominciò a guardare
questa mappa e dico Ma è possibile che
il Senegal ingloba gli cambia Ma perché
eh E lì ho cominciato a pensare ma
questa non è naturale non è non è una
condizione naturale il Gambia sta tutto
intorno al fiume Gambia quindi si prende
tutta l'acqua del diciamo di cui avrebbe
anche bisogno il Senegal e sono andata a
vedere storicamente cosa era accaduto
cosa era accaduto che lì c'era una
colonia inglese Quella era la porta del
dello schiavismo venivano caricate gli
africani sulle navi per andare negli
Stati Uniti dell'America Scusate non
c'erano ancora forse e si c'erano e
quindi era stata costruita questa erano
questa di costruiti questi paesi quando
se ne sono andati inglesi e francesi
dividendolo in questo modo assurdo
Quindi lì ho capito e mi ha affascinato
immediatamente la Geopolitica di cui io
non ero esperta che tutta la storia
umana la storia vera la storia umana e i
luoghi e la geografia avevano un nesso
incredibile e quindi questo mi ha ho
capito che se avessi seguito questo
filone di passione che Stava nascendo se
avessi osservato i territori in un certo
modo Sicuramente avrei potuto fare un
lavoro notevole e questo non mi sono mai
stancata di farlo naturalmente
ci stiamo parlando di come i popoli a
volte sono spesi nella conquista o nella
difesa dei Confini di come tenace e
sofferenza facciano parte della
geografia perché la geografia è
ridisegnata dall'umanità e quindi A
questo proposito ti chiedo il passaggio
che riguarda la Geo poesia perché siamo
arrivando Lino siamo partiti dalla
Geopolitica per arrivare in un'altra
dimensione questi che abbiamo citato
sono tutti elementi narrativi che ci
possono portare alla geoposia E allora
Raccontaci Che cos'è la geoposia che non
lo sappiamo la geografia è una mia
invenzione e nel senso che a un certo
punto tratta immaginate per 30 anni
tutti i giorni occuparsi di temi così
drammatici In fondo perché poi vedere
l'esempio che vi ho portato del Senegal
poi si capisce perché c'è l'immigrazione
o perché i paesi hanno tante difficoltà
quindi percepisci ehm la sofferenza
umana
Io ho cominciato a leggere delle poesie
un po' casualmente un po' per passione
per evadere E certo non è che ho scelto
dei Poeti proprio semplicissimi ma
insomma poetiche riguardano la guerra
perché per esempio Ungaretti e ho visto
che in mezzo a tante poesie ci sono del
toponimi toponimi però è interessanti
nascosti per esempio c'è pauselli che
scrive che è un poeta rumeno incredibile
Un universo di poesie e che scrive zona
dei popoli Muti in Germania la posizione
è se la Germania perché dal punto di
vista slavo loro talmente odiavano i
tedeschi che non potevano neanche
nominarli tedeschi Quindi lui nelle
poesie Usa questo modo di esprimersi che
è zona dei popoli muti per dire la
Germania lui era di madrelingua tedesca
viene ebreo quindi internato
sopravvissuto La mamma è uccisa dai
tedeschi quindi la lingua madre che
diventa doppia tragedia perché la lingua
madre della sua infanzia Ma era anche
degli assassini tutto questo scenario Ce
ne sono tantissimi esempi
risultato capire che nella geografia
umana si poteva come scendere nella
terra Cioè attraverso i sentimenti si
percepisce questa questo contatto
diciamo del nostro sentimento radicato e
che poi sale su attraverso la storia
attraverso il nostro tapis roulant per
spingersi in alto perché c'è un'altra
poetessa Abbiamo appena visto prima una
mappa di ingherba che lei racconta che
dopo la Seconda Guerra Mondiale dice si
può vivere solo in una terra tellurica
dove l'uomo l'essere umano può essere
rigenerato quindi immersione nel vulcano
naturalmente metaforico e dove l'ustione
e la fusione di questo essere umano che
aveva prodotto il nazismo quindi
parliamo della Mitte dell'Europa esplode
in una nuova generazione una nuova
cultura quindi tutta questo modo di
vedere la storia sotto altri punti di
vista e mi ha dato il coraggio un po' di
andare avanti a guardare il mondo in
faccia e poi di vedere anche questa
connessione con l'universo perché noi
facciamo parte di un insieme facciamo
parte di tutto uno spazio unico e sono
convinta che non ci siano spazi vuoti
cioè quello che noi vediamo quest'area
in realtà è tutto come il nostro corpo
umano all'interno è tutto un insieme e
questo io attraverso la poesia Non
riesco a percepire è molto affascinante
questo che ci stai raccontando tu spesso
parli anche che ogni paese ha una
calamita un centro e questo mi è sempre
molto colpito proprio per questo per la
geografia dell'umanità visto che il
nostro viaggio sta per chiudere anche se
siamo nei tempi Ti volevo chiedere
Secondo te com'è possibile che ognuno di
noi possa trasformare la geografia dei
propri luoghi di vita in qualcosa che è
deficit definibile come gioco poesia
Ognuno di noi ha una geografia fisica
che è quella del nostro corpo che porta
le sue cicatrici le sue Rughe e i segni
di quello che è accaduto nel corso della
vita e poi c'è la geografia dell'anima
dell'anima che profonde con questa
geografia fisica e secondo me l'ho
provato con me stessa Ci sono dei
momenti della vita in cui ci accorgiamo
perché c'è una grande emozione dovuta ai
venti che viviamo Naturalmente parlo di
cose che ci colpiscono anche intimamente
Nel senso che non sempre sono eventi che
noi possiamo
condividere con altri ma sono quelle
sensazioni improvvise o un pensiero
Quando un parente sta male quindi quella
cosa lì quella è un momento poetico e
noi dobbiamo dare spazio a questa cosa
la dobbiamo tenere perché fa parte della
nostra geografia dell'anima che si lega
a tutto quello che abbiamo visto
siccome tu ci hai raccontato anche che
in una mappa non si può mettere tutto No
giusto tu scegli mi hai raccontato non
si possono mettere tutte le città di un
paese ma scelgo quelle più importanti
Allora quello che ci stai dicendo per
semplificare è ognuno di noi può
individuare dei momenti essenziali della
sua vita e costruire la propria mappa
Geopolitica è questo che intendi
lasciarci come messaggio finale
assolutamente e mi auguro che tutti
quanti possiate riflettere sulla propria
passione e sui propri sentimenti perché
poi sono quelli che ci guidano e sono
quelli che ci arricchiscono grazie a
Laura canali che ci ha fatto fare questo
viaggio con
[Applauso]